verbucht
in deutschland machen wir das nie
ja ich weiß aber hier in berlin schon
ein beispiel für kinder
hallo leute herzlich willkommen zurück
bei einer neuen episode bei uns sind
heute nicole aus peru und jamie aus
kapstadt in südafrika sowieso toll
einmal fangen wie findet ihr eigentlich
das wetter in deutschland viel zu kalt
das ist viel zu kalt für mich
wie findest du das wetter verrückt
wetter verrückt es war zu kalt für mich
zum beispiel für mich winter asics und
gras oder so für uns ist heute ein ganz
normaler wintertag hier im januar in
berlin
deswegen haben wir uns gedacht weil die
beiden waren sind machen wollte mein
thema zum wetter das haben wir noch nie
gemacht und die mine werden heute mehr
menschen in berlin fragen wie das wetter
in deutschland ist wie es im sommer ist
wie es im winter ist was sie warm und
was sie kalt empfinden
fangen wir mal an oder
wie gefällt dir das wetter heute sehr
gut aber auch sehr schlecht aber es ist
kalt am anfang hat es mir gut gefallen
weil es sonnig war und man noch so ein
bisschen schnee gesehen hat aber jetzt
einfach nur kalt also nicht so gut
es ist wunderschön all die wahl hinter
den wolken die sonne scheint schön kalt
frisch vor nicht die sonne scheint also
ich mag es ich glaube gestern hat auch
geschneit aber heute ist es geblieben
auf den boden und na ja normalerweise
mag ich kein winter aber so mit sonne
und schnee das geht schon auf jeden fall
sehr gut ich bin froh dass es endlich
schneit
das ist angenehm kalt heute ist toll
aber es könnte noch ein bisschen kälter
sein dann würde der schnee liegen
bleiben
und was ist für dich eine kalte
temperatur mit 40 2 noch nie in kanada
ich würde sagen - 10 ist für mich kalt
alles unter 10 grad
was kälte ist also am liebsten schönsten
finde ich sind so eine klare frische
luft ist also wie soll ich sagen so
beißen kalt durch dringlich kalt ist ja
so wie jetzt aber es geht noch kälter in
deutschland es kann manchmal auch minus
zehn grad sein oder mehr noch jetzt
nicht auch eltern und was ist dein traum
wetter 20 grad und sonnenschein 20 grad
ok und für dich noch wärmer so dass ich
schütze ich liebe schwitzen 30 grad im
schatten oder hier strand auch hier über
25 deswegen muss jeder wechsel meistens
liege ich auch dann über januar/februar
meistens irgendwo in semmering und dann
erhöhung wetter mein traum mit
bis zu 27 grad sonne leichter wind der
sommer in deutschland ist
unterschiedlich also da wo ich herkomme
in münster gibt es manchmal gar keinen
richtigen sommer ist es vielleicht einen
monat war
und der rest ist so geht so aber hier in
berlin gibt es ein sehr langsamer und es
gibt ein mehr kontinentales klima das
heißt im sommer ist es wärmer und im
winter ist es kälter und das gefällt mir
sehr gut es gibt halt sommer oder winter
und nicht in münster manchmal ist es so
kann es im dezember genau so aussehen
wie im juni war ein traumwetter sind 20
bis 25 grad sonne ohne wind
uns ohne regen
mein traum wetter sind so 20 grad plus
sonne
das reicht mir schon jaja es müssen
keine drei so 20 grad sind nett
frühlingswetter traumwetter ich mag den
herbst eigentlich am meisten ja auch
sonnig aber halt auch so ein bisschen
frischer nicht so warm wie der sommer
hat es mindestens zu kalt jeden tag
gemütliche 20 grad
also dann hat man nicht das zu kalte das
zu warme also zu war wage ich auch nicht
zu kalt es auch die stimmen zum
mittelmaß
er liegt im weg und wann habt ihr regen
regen haben wir immer das ist nicht so
gut aber es kommt auch darauf an wo man
ist zum beispiel in norddeutschland hat
man mehr regen in westdeutschland
norddeutschland hat man mehr regen in
berlin habe ich das gefühl regnet es
weniger als in münster und in
süddeutschland oder auch zb schon in
köln es ist auch sonniger als in hamburg
zum beispiel und was ist dein traum
wetter am liebsten eigentlich richtig
war
mit sonne und alb
was ist die beste jahreszeit für dich
sommer ja lange helles und man viel
draußen sein kann und in deutschland wie
ist der sommer normalerweise
unterschiedlich manchmal richtig waren
manchmal nicht immer durchwachsen
irgendwie es kommt darauf an im winter
ist es schnee und kalt und im sommer ist
es warm und sonnig also beides gefällt
dir weil das gefällt mir
genau das war es schon mit unserer
episode heute jetzt habe ich euch mal
fandet ihr die antworten überraschend ja
ich kann nicht das kugellager für alle
es ist normal
du findest es zu kalt super kalt und
warst du auch überrascht verantworten
nein nicht so überrascht weil meine
familie wohnt in europa so ein
österreicher für sie ist das wetter
nicht so kalt und die sagen immer es ist
ja wenn es schneit ist es nicht so kalt
sie also ja das habe ich erwartet und du
persönlich findest du es kalt oder nicht
für mich ist es sehr kalt der schnee ist
sehr schön aber das ist viel zu kalt für
mich ist 15 grad auch sehr kalt also -
31 in deutschland wir freuen uns schon
auf 15 grad denn dann ist sommer für uns
jetzt wollen wir von euch wissen wie das
wetter in eurem land ist benutzen wir
die vokabeln die ihr heute gehört hat
schreibt uns in die kommentare wie ist
euer wetter und was findet ihr
eigentlich waren
und kalt was es für euch warm was ist
für euch kalt was ist euer traumwetter
und wenn ihr lust habt zu der episode
heute noch übungen zu machen also ihr
vokabular nochmal zu lernen oder
grammatik übungen zu machen dann werdet
unbedingt einen patch 1 bei isar germany
dort könnt ihr nämlich dann übungen
bekommen und auch die texte zu den
episoden
danke dass sie hier war und viel spaß
noch im winter hallo